قال ما قال الياهو إذا على طريقتك في غزة لا يوجد
غير متورط ولا ينبغي أن يقدم المساعدة
النقدية بالنسبة لك صباح الغد توقعاتك
أننا سوف نسقط ما يسمى بنوع من القنبلة الذرية
من أجل كل هذا، يقومون بتسويتها، والقضاء على الجميع
والذي فيه يأتي إلى صهيون الفادي من خلال هذا الطريق الوحيد
الطريقة الثانية أيضًا هي التحقق مما هو مهم بالنسبة لهم وما هو مخيف
لهم ما سيشكل الردع لهم
التالي
[موسيقى]
قلت عندما سألت من قبل ما إذا كنت سألقي الآن
نوع من القنبلة توم على كل شيء ثم على كل شيء ضمني
لأنك قلت أنه أحد الخيارات، نحن لا نفعل ذلك
مع الأخذ في الاعتبار أن لدينا 240 أو أكثر
هذا العدد الكبير من المختطفين الموجودين هناك
لا يجب أن تأخذ ذلك في الاعتبار، فأنت لست بحاجة إليها
لقد توسلنا إليك أن تعيد هؤلاء المختطفين إليك، هذا ما حدث
التي تحتاجها
ان يعمل
ه
لهذا السبب لا يوجد مكان ركضت فيه في باني، ولا يوجد بار
مثل هذا
ك
ال